[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
a guilty plea in the killing of a utah
college student
also arrests in an alleged plot to
kidnap the michigan governor
plus harsh words for harvey weinstein's
legal team
as new charges are filed and we will
remember them
for the way they lived their good and
decent lives
the department of justice plans to haul
two alleged terrorists to court
law and crime daily covers court cases
from coast to coast
[Music]
and welcome to law and crime daily
everybody i'm erin keller along with
brian buckmeyer and terry austin a
dramatic guilty plea
in the killing of a young woman in salt
lake city utah more than a year after a
college student's charred remains were
found
23-year-old mackenzie lewick disappeared
after taking a lyft home from her
grandmother's funeral
ayula ajahi admitted to strangling lueck
at his house
burning her body and burying it in his
backyard
ajahi's guilty plea came with a promise
by prosecutors not to seek the death
penalty
he's expected to be sentenced to life in
prison without the possibility of parole
later this
month the defendant admitted to meeting
lueck on an online dating website and
planning her murder before she arrived
at his house
he said he turned off his security video
cameras tied her hands behind her neck
and choked her he reportedly had a
contractor sound proof a room in his
home even
adding hooks in concrete walls and a
thumb lock
a jais plea included counts for the
forcible sexual abuse of a woman in a
separate case as well
prosecutors agreed to dismiss 19 felony
charges of sexual exploitation
of a minor stemming from child
pornography allegedly found in the
defendant's home
during the execution of a search warrant
so terry let's jump in with some
analysis right now the admitted level of
planning right here
is astonishing when we hear the admitted
charges
it is astonishing aaron and it makes you
think twice about
ever using a dating app the level of
planning
from the sound proofing to the fact that
he took his cameras
out i think we're kind of fortunate in a
way
that he was caught after this particular
murder because
to me it sounds as though he was
planning to do
multiple murders by creating an area
where he could do this and get away with
it
brian these are the kind of accusations
that are very hard for defense attorneys
if
you were defending this client would you
have advised him to take this deal or
how might you have defended him
well first i i don't advise clients to
take deals i merely
illustrate the pros and cons of a case
and help them understand
what those charges means if they were to
plead guilty and pleading guilty
ultimately is their choice however based
on the information we have here i may
lean a little bit harder
on the fact that he should take a plea
because identity is not an issue here
and you have a
decedent's body yeah brian i mean
the evidence just stacking up here again
the premeditation
the motive and whatnot this was a
clearer cut case for prosecutors and it
often is in many of the other cases we
look at here
it is i mean aside from the charred
remains and trying to prove identity you
look at his home
and the preparation in his home there's
no real good reason why an individual
have those items in their home
except for to murder someone and it's
really hard to work around that as a
defense attorney
and terry fair deal here a guilty plea
in exchange for taking the death penalty
off the table
well you know it's a horrible thing for
the family to have to go through and i
think that
probably is fair because now they don't
have to go through that trial
exactly we will be watching for the
formal sentencing michigan authorities
have announced the unraveling of a plot
to try to
kidnap the governor of that state six
men
are facing federal charges and seven
more are facing state charges including
conspiracy to kidnap
supporting terrorist acts and gang
membership some of the individuals are
believed to be part of a rogue militia
group
court documents say an undercover fbi
agent met with several members of the
group in june and recorded one of the
suspects saying
he needed 200 men to storm the state
capitol building
and take hostages including governor
gretchen whitmer here was some of her
response
hatred bigotry and violence have no
place
in the great state of michigan if you
break the law
or conspire to commit heinous acts of
violence
against anyone we will find you
we will hold you accountable and we will
bring you to justice
new reaction to the additional charges
levied in los angeles against former
movie producer harvey weinstein
weinstein faces the counts over the
alleged rapes of two women
a total of 11 women have accused
weinstein of sex crimes in california
as weinstein serves a 23-year sentence
in new york
the california crimes are said to have
occurred between 2004 and 2013.
brian buckmeyer you recently spoke with
weinstein's defense attorneys about the
process
to move the defendant to the west coast
yes i did aaron attorney imran ansari is
a frequent guest of the law and crime
trial network
he sheds some light on the process
prosecutors will use to pull weinstein
to the west coast
and how weinstein will fight the charges
remember the first batch of la charges
came just as weinstein's new york trial
was beginning
initially those initial charges on i
believe january 6 which was the eve of
jury selection
in the new york case now they added
these other charges
uh and uh we don't expect that they're
gonna back away from that and i i have a
feeling they're gonna be seeking
extradition
when that time is appropriate so imran
i'm glad you brought the point of
extradition because that's the next
question i wanted to follow up with
we know that harvey weinstein is being
held in buffalo new york
and there's a pending uh extradition
hearing coming up
early december can you give us your
thoughts about the mechanics of that and
how that might work out for him
specifically
sure well you know la was seeking
extradition earlier on
we were able to move that date uh to a
hearing december 11th
when the question of extradition is
again going to be before the court
and there are certain factors that need
to be taken into consideration that's
going to be
primarily uh the uh health emergency
that's really
shocking and rocking the country and
whether it's going to be safe
for him to be extradited at that time
that is going to be something that's
going to be looked at and if it's not
i would expect that arguments will be
presented to the court that extradition
is premature due to the health uh crisis
and dangers uh at hand so imran you
talked about the dangers of transporting
an individual
from one state to another yet alone new
york to california
are there any specific concerns or
general concerns that harvey weinstein
has
in terms of being transported from
buffalo new york to la california
yeah sure brian well you know of course
to protect uh my client's
privacy interest in his health
information i can't go into real
specifics but it's really no secret that
um
harvey weinstein is currently not in the
best state of health
um he has multiple problems with his
back and orthopedic problems
and that's why you saw him using the
walker during the trial he's also having
some other
health issues that really put him in in
a state where
he could be at risk so if transporting
him at a time when
uh coronavirus is really spiking in
either of these two areas
is something going to you know that the
court is going to have to consider
whether that they uh you know push
through this extradition to la
now imran as we're looking at this he's
facing a total of 11 counts of sexual
assault in
l.a there's are allegedly five women who
are coming forward based on these counts
what are harvey weinstein's position as
to these allegations
so harvey weinstein stands by what he's
been saying uh from inception regarding
these allegations and any allegations uh
that
you know nothing was non-consensual if
it even happened
and he intends to defend himself he
intends to put on a vigorous defense
and maintain his innocence in light of
these charges
weinstein accuser louise godbold said
the new charges brought her some comfort
but
also slammed one of weinstein's new york
trial attorneys
we're still obviously only scraping the
surface
and the sad thing about all of this is
that with the statute of limitations
there are very many people including
myself who will never get to see
our day in court is it possible to get
some sense of justice
looking at the way the cases are
proceeding that can proceed under the
statute of
it's gratifying that so many women have
come forward
and i came forward in order to support
them it's also very satisfying to be
able to support
my sisters the fellow survivors and
i have to say that rather than just
looking in um
punitive terms for harvey
it's also been a real lease of life to
have the connection with
all of these women who are pretty
amazing women what's some of their
reaction been to the additional charges
you know this is actually one
stage in a very long journey so
it's been an emotional roller coaster
all of us felt very invested
in the new york trial despite the fact
that only a few of us were actually
leading the charge on that one
so the collective sense
is that slowly the wheels of justice or
grinding
inextricably on the whole me too
movement
was an outcry from millions of women who
know exactly how we feel
so there are those women actually who
are still
dealing with their internalized misogyny
who will make comments about well they
should never gone up to that hotel room
it sounds like you may be speaking a
little bit there to donna rotuno
you got the reference donna rotuno was
disgusting
i i certainly hope that she's not still
on the scene
harvey doesn't like losers and she lost
so
i'm not sure that he will be employing
her again but who knows
but this is not a fight among women and
this is not a fight
between us and any particular attorney
this
is our desire to see justice done and
to make sure that harvey doesn't get out
of prison so that he can't hurt any more
women a wisconsin police officer will
not face charges for shooting a teenager
outside a suburban milwaukee mall
prosecutors there say wauwatosa officer
joseph mensah
had a reasonable belief that deadly
force was necessary in the february
shooting
17-year-old alvin cole was killed the
county district attorney released this
surveillance video
purportedly showing cole with a stolen
handgun authorities
or investigators rather say cole fired
around while fleeing from responding
officers
squad car video captures the chase cole
pointed the gun
in the direction of the officers reports
say and police
shot him five times and still ahead here
on law and crime daily a legal maneuver
by the school district
where the parkland school shooting
happened is drawing harsh criticism
from victims plus the attorney general
of kentucky files
new court papers demanding privacy not
transparency over the police shooting of
brianna taylor
our analysis right after this
[Music]
[Music]
kentucky attorney general daniel cameron
is fighting in court to prevent a grand
juror from speaking out about the police
shooting death of briana taylor
the ag's office filed court papers
arguing that allowing a grand jury to
talk would make a mess of the kentucky
legal system
because the public and prosecutors must
in his opinion
have confidence in the secrecy of the
grand jury process
cameron also noted that a grand juror in
missouri was prevented several years ago
from talking about the police shooting
of michael brown
and that a similar ban on grand jurors
speaking out should
also apply in kentucky so terry this is
an interesting concept an interesting
tactic from the ag here
to say secrecy should rule the day
should it why or why not
i absolutely think it should not prevail
and in fact transparency must prevail
of all cases this case is the case where
it took over
six months and you know march is when
she was shot and it wasn't until
september
that we got an indictment and the
indictment wasn't even for
the death of brianna taylor so that's
the one disturbing fact the other
disturbing fact is
that it was not transparent here and
initially the authority said there was
no body cam
and now all of a sudden there is body
cam so when you find that there are
issues that are you know different here
and you want to know exactly what the
grand jury saw
exactly and you know the other issue
we've got here brian is that police were
saying that uh
you know hey look uh you know there's a
high-powered weapon
that brianna taylor shot and now they're
turning around saying no that wasn't the
case so
terry got to jump to another story now
big case making waves the civil
litigation over the 2018
parkland florida shooting terry bring us
up to speed on that
well another big case making the ways
you're right parents who sued the
broward county school
district after their children were
killed are now being asked to prove
their mental anguish 17 students died in
the attack
at marjory stoneman douglas high school
many
of their parents are suing the school
blaming the district for failing to
identify
and stop the threat posed by the accused
shooter
nicholas cruz the district is now
demanding the parents turn over
their psychiatric records
it's relatively common in some civil
cases
for people to have to prove some
physical manifestation of injuries in
order to actually press a claim
so here is it required and if it is is
it
insensitive in a situation that's this
dramatic
well you know sometimes aaron you have
to show the length of the distress
or the you know severity of the distress
but you know in this type of case where
you have
children who were shot and killed and
the parents are
obviously showing some emotional
distress the
witnesses should be able to testify you
should not have to go
into their psychiatric records or their
you know physical
records from their physicians so i think
that the
county is really pushing here and it
is an invasion of privacy so brian
oftentimes lawyers have to do things
that
rub people the wrong way in defense of a
client or an organization is this one of
those cases or do you think they should
just
handle this a different way
i think this might be one of those
situations where lawyers are going to
get the short on the stake in the public
eye
another way to look at it is that the
defense attorney here or the ones
representing the school district have to
ensure that the claims are
serious enough that when it comes to
negotiating or whether or not to go to
trial
they have to protect the interests of
their clients and also the students who
still reside there
taking money out of their pockets is not
helpful for the school district and that
framing of the mindset i think is how
defense attorneys really
go about this it's a tough legal
situation but
again in theory the district could just
say we're going to waive this if it
wanted
coming up on law and crime daily texas
authorities charge a charge netflix
rather with a crime over a controversial
new film and
the u.s department of justice plans to
haul two suspected terrorists into
american courts to answer for the
killings
of citizens overseas
[Music]
two alleged isis terrorists are now on
u.s soil to face the american criminal
justice system
former british citizens alexander cote
and al-shafi al-shaikh
were part of the isis guards known as
the beatles
the group is believed to be tied to
dozens of kidnappings and responsible
for the deaths of at least
four americans the u.s had to agree to
not seek the death penalty in exchange
for the men's extradition
the men face up to life in prison if
convicted of eight charges involving
hostage taking and terrorism
here is the department of justice's
message for the victims families
and for the accused today's announcement
is the result of many years of hard work
in the pursuit of justice for these
americans
we have been inspired by their memories
and moved by the determination and
grit of their families families which
will never rest
until justice is done to them
i say this neither will we
as for cote now shake like many other
terrorists before them
they have underestimated the american
resolve to obtain
justice for our fellow citizens who are
harmed or killed by terrorists anywhere
in the world
these men will now be brought before a
united states court to face justice for
the depraved acts alleged against them
in the indictment the doj also paused to
remember the victims and share
their stories james foley was a print
and video journalist who was covering
the civil war in syria
he had previously served as a conflict
zone correspondent in iraq
and then in libya james was a former
elementary school teacher stephen
sotloff was a journalist who covered the
middle east and was in syria reporting
on the refugee crisis
according to a longtime friend he was
drawn to the region to quote
give a voice to the people who didn't
have one close quote
stephen was the grandson of holocaust
survivors who inspired him to be that
voice
peter kasich was in syria working for a
humanitarian organization that he
founded to deliver food
and medical aid to the refugees he had
previously served as an elite airborne
ranger
in the u.s army which included service
in iraq
kayla mueller was a humanitarian aid
worker and human rights
activist who inspired by her faith
devoted much of her young life to
serving those in need
both at home and abroad as president
trump shared during his 2020 state of
the union address
the american warriors who conducted the
military operation
that resulted in the death of isis
leader abu bakr al-baghdadi
were in so inspired by kayla that they
named the mission
task force 814 a reference to august
14th
kayla's birthday and when we come back
here on law and crime daily killer dead
chris watts
getting some attention while behind bars
from some
interesting admirers on crime daily
returns in just a moment
let's wrap up now with a couple of other
cases in the news right now colorado dad
chris watts
admitted he murdered his wife and
children but he's apparently getting fan
mail in prison
people magazine reports that watts is
spending his time behind bars
corresponding with multiple women
the magazine cites an unnamed source
saying the pen pals
thought watts was handsome and felt
compassion for him
even though he murdered his family after
meeting a new girlfriend
watts had nothing better to do the
magazine report so he started writing
back
and the conversations kept going netflix
is facing
interesting legally here indicting a
company on a criminal charge explain
that for us
well you know under the law corporations
are considered legal persons so they can
be sued both civilly and criminally and
in texas that fine could triple
or double because if the court finds
that the company
benefited financially then the penalty
goes up
so we could be facing up to about twenty
thousand dollars here brian got to ask
you about chris watts here
uh what's going on with the pen pals
behind prison walls if he was your
client would you tell him to be
answering these people back or does he
just have nothing to lose at this point
i don't think he has anything to lose
aaron and when i was single
i was trying to find a date in new york
but somehow my clients could find dates
all the time
i don't know what it is clients always
have admirers out there and it just
seems to be another par for the course
yeah i mean i guess when you've got
nothing but time on your hands
when you're behind prison you can
respond to questions like that so brian
terry appreciate the
insight here on these many cases that
we've been talking about on long crime
daily
appreciate very much you joining us for
these discussions about justice in
america
we'll see you back here next time and of
course live trials on law and crime
network
[Music]
you